- [Voiceover] There's three things
that are most important to chefs.
First is flavor,
second is flavor,
and third is flavor.
Flavor rules.
(tractor putting)
- [Voiceover] Built on the
fertile former-lake-bottom soil
of northern Ohio, The
Chef's Garden is a 300-acre
family farm that grows specialty produce
for some of the world's best restaurants.
- The Chef's Garden is a small family farm
that has the good fortune
of working directly
with some of the greatest
chefs in the world.
In many cases we're
working with plant growers
that are breeding to be
able to create new plants,
not genetic modification
but genetic selection.
- [Voiceover] The farm grows produce
of all shapes and sizes,
like miniature carrots,
these white strawberries,
and almost 100 varieties of microgreens.
But the Jones family wasn't
always The Chef's Garden.
- My parents had had some
very successful years.
In 1983 they had a very
devastating hailstorm
and ultimately the farm collapsed.
We were dealt a new deck of cards
and found opportunity within a disaster.
We met a European-influenced
Chef, Iris Baylen.
Said: "Grow me varieties for flavor.
"Grow me varieties without chemical.
"I want a zucchini bloom."
Thought this lady was absolutely crazy.
Little did we know, she
knew a heck of a lot
more about it than we did.
And that really opened our eyes
to another whole world out there.
We hooked up with some
really great chefs early on,
folks like Danielle Balou
and John George Von Richten
and Alain Ducasse and Michel Richard,
and then Thomas Keller and Charlie Trotter
and Ritz Carlton chefs
and Four Season chefs.
And they've allowed us an
existence in agriculture.
We're indebted to those
chefs that have given us
the privilege and the path to be able
to follow our dream of farming.
So it's that symbiotic relationship
of chef and farmer working
together for the greater good.
And here we are 35 years later
still working to get better.
- To the best of our ability,
right now, in this place,
I think we're doing the right thing,
and I think that trumps every other reason
for whatever you do in this life.
(soft acoustic guitar music)